you might not have known this but
ancient egypt was an itchy place to live
lice were rampant cleopatra for example
was buried with solid gold lice cones
while other egyptians would shave their
entire bodies to try and get rid of the
parasites
it's a problem we've had for a while and
we probably won't be solving it anytime
soon humans and lice have been living
together for about seven million years
when our ancestors first split from
chimps and we've been itching to get rid
of them
ever since there are 532 species of lice
out there
but let's take a look at the most common
type that plagues humans
head lice for starters they have six
legs and each one has a tiny hook at the
end
that helps them climb from one head to
the other
latch onto your hair and quickly crawl
down to your scalp
where they'll feast on your blood
several times a day
and once they've made themselves
comfortable lice
are tricky to spot adult lice for
example are about as
large as a sesame seed while baby lice
or nymphs are a fraction of that size
are well camouflaged too matching the
color of the hair around them
not to mention your scalp is the perfect
breeding ground
in one day a female louse can lay up to
8 eggs
those eggs only take about a week to
hatch once they're 10 days old
they'll start laying eggs of their own
while it's rare to find more than 20
live lice on any head
there could be dozens or even hundreds
of dead
bodies lingering on your scalp
are you feeling itchy yet perhaps even
worse
is that they're a pain to get rid of
lice can hold their breath
for eight hours so they'll be fine when
you go take a shower or go for a swim
they're also notorious for developing
resistance to insecticides
during world war ii for example
militaries dusted millions of europeans
with ddt
to control lice-borne typhus and thanks
to our overuse of it
lice grew a resistance to the poison
even today we're still seeing the
repercussions from it
many over-the-counter shampoos and
lotions use similar killing mechanisms
to ddt
which in some places has made it easier
for lice to grow resistant to these
treatments as well
but scientists are striking back in the
last decade
experts have developed new weapons of
attack for when initial over-the-counter
treatments don't work
like ivermectin lotion which paralyzes
lice
by disrupting their nervous systems and
of course
shaving your head like the egyptians is
a cheap and surefire bet
but let's face it most of us probably
can't pull off that look